up until like Australia Pittacus or
something yeah what really seems to
matter though is the ratio of brain size
to body size right there are plenty of
animals that have bigger brains than us
that aren't just obviously aren't
smarter than us like elephant elephants
blue whales I mean a blue whale brains
probably the size of this room do we
know if elephants are [ __ ] super
smart because isn't the thing about
intelligence is not just like there's
communication between elephants for sure
and you know that they recognize each
other after long periods of time yeah
like 20 years apart they get together
and they see each other and recognize
each other instantly sure so there's a
there's an intelligence there but what
we judge intelligence oftentimes depends
on whether or not it can communicate
with you whether or not it changes its
environment builds a structure I mean
that's to me this is one of the deepest
questions in life do you see the
elephant that painted a picture of its
Shore yeah that's crazy
yeah and Thailand I think yes yeah pull
that up that is one of those things
where you go okay wait a minute
a dog can't do that I thought you said
this thing was as smart as a dog because
that's yeah that's a hundred times and
there are like grey parrots that have
you know 300 word vocabularies or
something yeah I mean I know don't quote
me on the number but Jamie can look that
up there is they can speak a whole like
sentence yeah and they can and there's a
guy I remember seeing this recently
there's a guy as a border collie who
obviously can't talk but understands
well over a hundred words and so what
he'll do is like you'll put all these
different toys behind a wall and you'll
say go get me the the yellow bunny and
there's like a yellow bunny a red bunny
and a green bunny in addition to
hundreds of other [ __ ] and the dog will
go find the yellow bunny and bring it
back whoa you know go get me the you
know the green turtle and you'll go get
it so the dog knows those words right
and also the dog sees in color I guess
it's a predator I guess I've never seen
color yeah I think so here's the the
elephant painting itself it is [ __ ]
crazy because it really looks like
itself and this guy helps it and gets
the brush and puts it in its hand but
the elephant is essentially doing all of
this with its trunk
just replicating itself and it's
proportional to its it's really like the
dude was holding his tusk yeah to do
that I think well I'm sure they're
training or is he just pulling the brush
goes where does he look at the trunk
like he's definitely holding but look at
the trunk and look at how much motion is
in that thing how could he possibly be
controlling that he's definitely lifting
it up and down and helping him though
yeah but there what it is is they're
working together like the elephant knows
to stay in these lines it's doing it
with him you're not buying it the Tusk
is a little there's another one there
are other ones but let me see the other
one just articles that say that they're
being trained to do it and it's a cruel
or something okay this one right here
this thing doesn't have anybody's hands
on it I think this is the one that I had
seen before
let's see if this in any case is a
question of intelligence is so much more
complicated than we generally credited
with right not only among animals but
also among humans there's this big
controversy that's you know perennial
controversy that's the problem right now
we're constantly looking at another
video this is the one that I had seen
and it's nobody's nobody's touching it's
nobody's controlling him here and well
he doesn't have any tusks it looks like
does he know so that looked like the guy
was just giving him the brush and he was
doing it why don't they pull back though
so you could see if that's true
see this is the one that I had seen
before you hadn't seen the other one
yeah this is unassisted I would imagine
that if you did get a guy like this that
teaches his elephant how to how to paint
a [ __ ] picture that you're gonna it's
gonna become a tourist attraction right
people gotta say come and watch the
elephant that paints the picture you
might as seen on YouTube and then next
thing you know you got a tourist
business well if he always does the same
picture to right draws himself over and
over again yeah but it's right here it
looks to me at least like the elephant's
doing that you couldn't even talk a
four-year-old into doing that
so you know I'm saying look for yourself
it you have to ask him what the [ __ ] it
is like what is that like that's an
elephant whoa that elephant's crazy what
does it do it you think it knows it's
drawing an elephant or it's it's a good
question like this drawing a tree it
probably doesn't know it's drawing an
elephant if I had a guess I would get
out of guess that it probably doesn't
understand 2d space like that because if
it did it would start creating art they
start expressing themselves to each
other they were start drawing directions
let's go this way if you start seeing
animals do that that is so far beyond
using tool that's what bees do yeah
Ready's do with smells right well they
do with exams yeah they can they give
instructions on where the flowers are